Hola qué tal bueno siguen los festejos
aquí de alguna gente bueno bastante
gente en la zona en torno al obelisco al
final la Caravana no pasó por la zona no
pasó por aquí se concentró tanta tanta
tanta gente en el camino se está
volviendo peligroso había gente subida a
los puentes por donde pasaba el bus con
la selección algunas personas saltaron
al bus hay videos de una persona
saltando y una persona que que tuvo la
mala fortuna de caer al suelo varias
caídas desde altura y entre ante esas
circunstancias al final se decidió
desviar ese bus y que los jugadores de
la selección sobrevolaran en helicóptero
la ciudad para saludar desde el
helicóptero a la hinchada alguna de las
personas que estaban esperando aquí se
sintieron un poco frustradas y
decepcionadas así me lo dijeron y otros
siguen celebrando y contentos Por Este
triunfo de la selección nacional en
Argentina